[Music]
in welcome to the family is welcome
family Oh a little bit of [ __ ] and
family something else man I know but you
heard me say action that's your fine
whatever what where's our my 69 a little
bit of 69 a little bit of [ __ ]
he doesn't like 69 I don't it reminds me
of high school I like doing stand-up 69
and Nicki does like to do it that's not
true let me you're tall enough to
[ __ ] flip her upside down yeah but my
torso is not that long you know like you
end up with your head on a [ __ ] dick
[Laughter]
I'm very long we've moved on this is
submitted by snake and Mambo oh yes take
him up here a woman is engaged to her
son's best friend who she's known since
he was 11 years that's [ __ ] dream
dude someone's hot mom you actually
conquered it and you're now your best
friend's [ __ ] stepdad that is the
most mom's I know are not hot but we
always do one right you always knew one
kid oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah my best
friend in elementary I didn't realize my
friend was pretty Forrest Gump II until
I got older he was a veteran yeah you'd
like to running a lot it's crazy I
actually had a lot of friends that were
kind of like delayed yeah because you
guys did drugs all the time no I'm
talking about elementary school
kindergarten first grade their moms did
drugs all
because you were in a delayed class I
was not in specialist you gotta think of
it all my freshmen regular school all
right so this mom she's 39 she's engaged
for her son's best friend who's 18 oh my
god they have known each other 13 and 39
the joke's on him though he said she
said the thing that we all agree with
and then use the nothing that we don't
that ain't got split in half okay in my
head like I always thought he wasn't in
the delayed class 13 doesn't look like
18 to you Oh 13 listen listen listen if
you get 18 you you cut a line in between
to catch a predator video right now
looks like this shit's crazy I'm Chris
Hansen Chris [ __ ] dude that was [ __ ]
funny okay so they only been dating for
three months but I mean two months and
they're already but they known each
other for a lifetime yeah so what a
great love way do we have pics do we
have pissed because you know what like
if all's I 11 and then I was like man
this girl's so ha one day i'ma make her
my wife what that means like seven years
ago she was only 31 or two or some [ __ ]
like that right yeah so that's that
there's a lot of hot 32 years year-olds
right I'm only thinking from the boys
perspective like reverse molestation
right so like I'm the molested but then
I have I'm like I'm like I'm like I have
I'm just picturing myself with my friend
my special friends hot mom right she was
a chola that's real crap the Gumpy one
the form people how does he do it he's a
[ __ ] genius dude you this guy will
dig himself a grave this
[ __ ] fill it in so by the way my
friend is is a little funny because he
got dog [ __ ] and he rubbed it all over
my shirt one day so that's how I
realized how special he was maybe my
friend was special because you got a
used tent you used pad and rubbed it
yeah well what she was she laughing in
tears and not realizing how wrong it was
no see me how wrong it was
okay then she's about that special was
she saying this shouldn't be wrong maybe
that's she was making a statement but
anyways I fell in love with his mom at
that moment when when he rubbed [ __ ] all
over my shirt right because she took my
shirt and then she washed it for me and
that shirt came back smelling really
good and she was doing chores that day
and she was on all fours like cleaning
something and I looked at her ass and I
was like oh my god I'm in love how old
are you I was in like fourth grade about
that age nine ten yeah about that age I
don't know what to do with that ass I
didn't know what to do I see I just knew
you liked it that is the moment that I
fell in love when she bent over on all
fours and I was like something about his
mom I don't know what's going on
instinctually right and it's like let's
say if I turn 18 and then I she's still
hot by the way then I grew out with her
that's different right
she still has but she was like a bit
piranha she was a chola I want to see
the photos I want to see the problems
let me tell you so Chase is 18 year old
and then so he met the mother of three
named Jamie who's 39 when he was 11 and
he became best friends with Jamie's
oldest son who's now 16 and then here's
some photos
Oh No dang brutal okay they go on double
dates with her son what you got no stamp
well I guess both of them are pretty ugh
where okay where do they live
good follow Bama West Virginia Kentucky
up Kentucky from Kentucky's not known
for incest dude these are her kids and
then net he's a stepdad to these kids oh
my god [ __ ] weird dude hey they all
love each other already so who cares I
think she asked him to get married no he
keeps proposing he's proposed to her
over 300 times now he can't keep she
can't get her off of his mind yep so
they like so these are her kids and then
him I think she's like that's my husband
and that's my kids and that's your way
different every day playing video games
dear friend he's always time while your
[ __ ] mom dude yeah your son's body
looks the same as your husband's love
fiance yeah didn't fit and then this is
like oh no I'm not grooming that's
illegal as [ __ ] yeah that's exactly what
it is
oh yeah [ __ ] swimming but you guys don't
know what if he was predatoring her
though well that's what they say a child
a child can't produce her anybody eat
I'm telling you from personal experience
when I saw my friend's mom bend over I
wanted her good but you don't know cuz
they're your child that's like when
girls think they want some older guy
because they have daddy issues and stuff
it's like I don't have mommy issues I
like that I know but it's the same kind
of thing where the child cannot make a
decision like that you have it okay
childlike Jo right is he really that
different than now no but at least now
you could be like okay that's really his
decision Archie
like where's before it's like I wish my
parents were polar bears you know it's
like you know you don't know you know I
really wish that I think that's a reason
Morgan so they're saying that they got
really close when he went out jogging
with her to like help her lose she jogs
Oh
so you lost like a hundred pounds now so
he helped her lose weight so he loved
her when she was fat that's real love
see that's real [ __ ] look I think
this is grooming I think motoki's right
this was grooming dude I don't like it
this is pretty crazy this no I'm usually
went to school with his mom too and so
like how does her mom feel about it
initially they didn't like it and but
now they give them their blessings so
because it's true love question interest
if you are that that kid whose mom and
best friend is you know about to get
married yeah imagine yourself being that
kid would you want your best friend to
ask you to be his best man it looks like
it looks like he's not opposed to it
he's like happy for his mom hey he has
to call him daddy now can you imagine
calling your bestfriend daddy that's
kind of cool why I think it's the
ultimate trol in a way because how many
stories have we done where the girls the
girls and runs away with the dad oh
that's disgusting
that's [ __ ] no that's pedophile right
there I think this this is like Ashton
Kutcher [ __ ] with any more right I think
that he got her so good that you know
mean he goes with her and then he then
he dumped her randomly out of nowhere
huh I think that that was like a similar
thing
maybe there was a bet involved some [ __ ]
this seems like a [ __ ] troll dude
he's getting his friends so [ __ ] good
right I'm like in a year from now he's
like dude what's my name he's like dad
and he's like man I [ __ ] die and then
his friends like oh you [ __ ] got you
so good
that's the Steve that's like they're
playing xbox when they're nine years old
and they're like like dude I [ __ ] your
mom the other day they're like no you
did it [ __ ] you it goes just watch and
he actually did it and then you [ __ ]
he [ __ ] wish Walden dude he put it
all over his wall what he's gonna do at
a Pinterest wall he's [ __ ] damn dude
I gotta make this work if she lost some
weight okay I'll take a run it he's like
all be part of her weight-loss journey
yeah he [ __ ] inception the shoe and
India like see I [ __ ] your mom that's
how you weaponize the secret
and get some sick revenge against your
Xbox that you would do [ __ ] you that
seems more plausible than anything
because I one look at that mom and I was
like what the [ __ ] she was a tenth
here's the thing she was a ten
I'd be like god bless this kid he should
be knighted in London you should be
knighted in London Penn how do you know
her personality I'm sure she makes great
Bologna cheese sandwiches but like
honestly what I'm sure her cookies are
to die for it it's easier to back the
boy up if the mom was hot as hell well
that's why he had her lose some lady
that was a ten that kid should be in
[ __ ] Nuremberg getting a Nobel Peace
Prize 100% yep
well he says that he loves her
personality you see that he wanted to
marry her right away there's so many
things he likes about her like her great
sense of humor that she stops him from
being lazy she could drive she's a
better mother figure than his old mom
she could buy an alcohol I don't know
man I
I think I'm against this now I think
this is wrong what's the age of consent
in Kentucky probably 13 60 and 12 in
Ohio at 16 yeah Paulie 16 Jude in Mexico
explode - it's like what fer sex really
yeah that's cuz in Mexico isn't at the
Kinson era is like when you become a
woman and then you can so you're ready
you're ready to like make babies age of
consent and make it go it is 15 15 15
I'm going 15 kids in it right so wait
complex complex there is no consent
there is no age of consent that's what
it is it says they have a primary age of
consent which may be as low as 12 means
people are [ __ ] less than 12 that's
gross man it's just like I mean just
like here where you read about some
14-year old [ __ ] and you're like wait
and then they say age of consent law is
14 like what well it's like yeah it's
like if you make the drinking age 21 it
means 18 year-olds are drinking if you
make it 18 that means you know 15
year-olds are drinking yeah so like you
make the age of consent law 18 it means
you know 15 year-olds are [ __ ] yeah
so if it's the age of consent 12 that
means 4 can the age that you can go in
the military is 18 you know they're
going
or [ __ ] 16 and that means I've know
when I'm - because when I was 21 to
drink
I was drinking like 12 [ __ ] that you
flip though numbers huh damn that's
crazy but it's disgusting I know we
danced is oh so gross kid my friend my
friend's mom looked like a Mexican like
lady on Baywatch
who imagine that's tied it up she looked
like a 90s like no one like a rocker
girl good oh my god yes your friend
should have been carried everywhere he
went on a [ __ ] chair on a [ __ ]
King Jeter yeah please Ryan got there he
accomplished the dream yep
[Music]